Stuart rush says he wants accountability
for what happened to his family on
Saturday December 3rd Karen kermas was
arrested on DUI and reckless driving
charges accused of hitting them this is
the fourth time in the past 15 years she
has faced such charges
come on you had three DUI with reckless
driving she got a DUI reckless driving
with substantial bodily harm the night
she hit my granddaughter and son-in-law
she shouldn't even been driving Stuart
rush says his three-year-old
granddaughter is suffering from mental
trauma she has troubles remembering
certain things and has physical injuries
that are slowly healing it's a miracle
they survived I mean we're grateful
every day with our granddaughter and
with Ernesto Ernesto cancino the child's
father was in a coma for days following
the crash this week he was moved out of
the trauma unit at UMC butts remains
hospitalized with brain injuries police
say Karen kermos was traveling south on
Nellis went around the car stopped at a
red light and ended up hitting the bike
cancino and his daughter were on in a
marked crosswalk at Charleston I'm sorry
it's a slap in the face when she's out
on bail and my son-in-law is still in
the hospital rush says cancino shielded
the three-year-old when he saw the
oncoming car taking the brunt of the
impact his recovery will be a long one
yet they're grateful it didn't end up
much worse I'm just thankful every day
that they're alive and that they're
still here you know what I'm saying
because I mean it's nothing short of a
miracle that they survived at
you can't buy a car 60 miles an hour
now karma karma has told police after
the crash he takes medications due to
health issues officers say she mumbled
Her speech at the scene and found her
eye pupils were dilated she has been
ordered not to operate any motor vehicle
Christian